sie ist eines der größten naturwunder
der welt
mehr als 1,7 millionen liter wasser
stürzen ihr pro sekunde in die tiefe
aber
zum zeitpunkt der aufnahme dieses videos
an die iguazú wasserfälle leider so
[Musik]
in unserem heutigen video sehen wir uns
einen der schwierigsten aspekte des
klimawandels an ich weiß viele sprechen
ständig über klima aber wie sieht es in
der welt konkret aus nun zur zeit leider
südamerika unter der schlimmsten dürre
der letzten 70 jahre diese dürre
betrifft vor allem brasilien argentinien
und paraguay
[Musik]
und glaubt mir wir reden hier von einer
krise die brutale folgen haben könnte
vor allem in argentinien hast du schon
mal was von paraná fluss gehört viele
von euch haben wahrscheinlich noch nie
von diesem fluss gehört aber er ist das
rückgrat dass diese ganze region
verbindet dabei geht es nicht nur um die
landwirtschaft sondern auch und strom
und verkehr mit anderen worten ein
versiegen dieses flusses könnte
katastrophale folgen für diese länder
nach sich ziehen aber ist die lage
wirklich schon so ernst in diesem video
werden wir das klären
[Applaus]
[Musik]
linien ist berühmt für tango peronismus
und die argentinische pampa die riesigen
landwirtschaftlichen flächen die das
rückgrat der argentinischen wirtschaft
bilden aber es gibt in argentinien ein
sprichwort wenn etwas schiefgehen kann
geht es in argentinien noch schiefer
[Musik]
in argentinien hat man sich eine
permanente debakel gewöhnt vor der
hyperinflation über staatspleiten bis
hin zur massiven abwanderung von
unternehmen es gab jedoch eine sache die
in diesem land noch funktionierte die
landwirtschaft damit du dir ein bild
machen kannst argentinien ist der
drittgrößte produzent von sojabohnen
weltweit und glaubt mir argentinische
sojabohnen werden in die ganze welt
verkauft sie werden nicht nur zur
herstellung von sojamilch und den
produkten verwendet sie sind auch das
haupt futtermittel für nutztiere
argentinien brasilien und paraguay
gehören zu den hauptproduzenten die
sojabohnen werden in der pampa angebaut
die hauptsächlich durch das wasser des
paraná flusses verbessert wird
[Musik]
nach der ernte werden die bohnen in
booten transportiert die ebenfalls den
paraná fluss hinunter fahren das heißt
statt lastwagen werden lastkähne
eingesetzt mit denen tonnen von getreide
flussaufwärts grund flussabwärts
transportiert werden können fast die
gesamte wirtschaft dieser drei länder
hängt zu einem großen teil vom fluss
verkehr aber du kannst das sprichwort
wenn etwas schiefgehen kann wird ist in
argentinien noch schief gehen
[Musik]
die schlimmste dürre seit einem
jahrhundert trifft brasilien während ist
mit der überwindung von cobit kämpft
aber ist das wirklich so eine
katastrophe was sind die wirklichen
folgen dieser dürfe was genau geht in
brasilien argentinien und paraguay
gerade vor sich heute werden der all
diese fragen beantworten aber zuerst
müssten sie ein wenig geld verdienen
hier kommt also die werbung und unser
heutiger sponsor ist server ibm ein
wirklich sicheres vpn dass weder
datenverkehr noch meter oder
verbindungsdaten mit glaubt und außerdem
jede menge security tools mitbringt ist
aber auch aus vielen anderen gründen ein
ganz tolles happy end natürlich könnt
ihr mit dessen hilfe auf webseiten und
internet dienste zugreifen die in dem
land in dem er gerade seiten nicht
verfügbar sind ohne zensur und glocken
ob daheim oder im urlaub darüber hinaus
bietet es aber noch jede menge
sicherheitsfeatures habt ihr nicht zum
beispiel auch ein mulmiges gefühl durch
die allgegenwärtigen der die pop-ups und
cookies mit surft bekommt er ein
handliches tool namens clean web dass
die alle bloggt und die damit
verbundenen gefahren beseitigt und nicht
nur das mit nur einem server konto könnt
ihr alle eure geräte im vpn registrieren
handys notebooks oder sogar euren smart
tvs denkt wirklich alle arten von
geräten ab so und weil wir euch unsere
treuen fans so lieb haben waren wir nur
bereit ist es konsens nur übernehmen
wenn euch surf auch einen ordentlichen
rabatt einräumt und das ist uns gelungen
mit hilfe des rabattcodes politik.de
bekommt ihr sage und schreibe 83 prozent
rabatt und obendrein noch die ersten
drei monate gratis dazu denn links zu
diesem angebot findet ihr in der
beschreibung unter diesem video also
nichts wie los sagte szostak und hält
damit gleichzeitig auch ist dann für
euch weiterhin so nette videos wie
dieses hier liefern können und nun auf
nach lateinamerika
dass saudi arabien des wassers ich bin
mir sicher dass viele von euch schon vom
problem der wasserknappheit gehört haben
viele sind der meinung dass wasser eine
zunehmend knappe ressource sein wird
wenn es jedoch einen kontinent gibt er
sich keine sorgen machen muss dann ist
bis lateinamerika
[Musik]
auch lateinamerika unfall nur acht
prozent der weltbevölkerung aber 30
prozent der weltweiten
niederschlagsmenge der referenz index
zur messung von wasserknappheit ist der
sogenannte formen mark waters traisental
benannt nach der schau die ihn erfunden
hat diesem index zufolge sind nur drei
länder in lateinamerika anfällig für das
was man wasserstress nennt brasilien
allein ist mit 12 bis 16 prozent des
gesamten süßwassers dieses planeten
gesegnet ein unvorstellbarer reichtum
viele bezeichnung ist daher als das
saudi arabien des wassers und in
brasilien genauer gesagt regionen minas
gerais entspringt der paraná viele von
euch haben wahrscheinlich noch nie im
leben von ihm gehört dennoch ist er der
acht längste fluss der welt wenn wir
alle nebenflüsse mitzählen wir reden
hier von fast 4800 flusskilometern schon
einmal diese karte an
[Musik]
hier kannst du sehen wie der paraná in
brasilien entspringt und durch paraguay
fließt auf der höhe dieses landes
entsteht der wichtige nebenfluss dieses
stroms schiffbar ist die rede ist von
paraguay fluss danach ist der paranoia
seinen lauf in richtung argentinien fort
und endet in der nähe von buenos aires
doch egal wie viel wasser dieser fluss
hat bis in die 70er jahre waren den
menschen in dieser region angewöhnt
deswegen da man damals ein monumentales
projekt in angriff ein riesiges
kanalsystem der paraná paraguay hydro
tech und so überraschend es wirklich
auch klingen mag dieses projekt ist eine
der größten gemeinschaftlichen
erfolgsgeschichten südamerikas
[Musik]
denn wenn für lateinamerika etwas
charakteristisch ist dann dass die
länder einander nicht vertrauen kaum
handel miteinander treiben und viele
probleme mit der zusammenarbeit haben
der mercosur zum beispiel war ein
versuch ein freihandelsabkommen zwischen
den lateinamerikanischen ländern zu
schaffen aber wenn wir bereits in
früheren videos erwähnt haben hat er
kaum einen zweck erfüllt die
wasserstraße paraná paraguay ist dagegen
eine echte erfolgsgeschichte und
deswegen werden wir uns dieses projekt
mal etwas genauer ansehen
[Musik]
das rückgrat der pampa
ich weiß dass viele von euch denken
einfluss für warentransport zu nutzen
ist doch eine triviale angelegenheit
schließlich muss man den fluss nicht
bauen er ist er einfach schon da und
wenn er tief genug ist kann man ihnen
doch einfach mit booten befahren super
einfach nein ganz so einfach ist es
nicht und waren auf einem fluss zu
transportieren braucht es eine menge
infrastruktur zunächst einmal müssen wir
die flächen abschnitte auswandern das
heißt wir müssen den boden des flusses
säubern um sicherzustellen dass er immer
einen bestimmten wasserstand hat der ist
großen schiffen erlaubt ihm zu passieren
außerdem müssen wir wegweiser dämme und
so weiter aufstellen aber wir reden
nicht nur über technik der paraná fluss
fließt durch drei verschiedene länder
paraguay argentinien und brasilien um
die wasserstraße ist was zu machen muss
man also diese drei länder an einen
tisch bringen so dass sie dort
gemeinsame regeln schaffen und wenn du
denkst das wäre ein einfaches
unterfangen dann schau dir mal die
konflikte zwischen ägypten und äthiopien
um den nil an doch in diesem fall
konnten argentinien brasilien und
paraguay ihrer nationalistischen f3
seite schieben und sich auf etwas
einigen das in dieser region unbekannt
zu sein schien freie schifffahrt mit
anderen worten die rede auf der paranoia
wasserstraße müssen sich registrieren
lassen aber wenn sie das getan haben
können sie den gesamten fluss relativ
frei befahren und wenn eines dieser drei
länder eine steuer auf dem fußball acker
erheben will muss sich mit den anderen
ländern einigen
[Musik]
und du wirst sagen wirklich gibt es
wirklich keine debatten über die
nationalen ansprüche nun die wahrheit
ist das ist einige fraktionen des
radikalen peronismus in argentinien gibt
welche die hoheit auf dem fluss
beanspruchen aber es haben sich dabei um
eine minderheit zumindest im moment noch
hinzu kommt dass die meisten banker
arbeiten im argentinischen teil des
flusses von einem privaten übernehmen
durchgeführt werden und nicht einmal von
einem argentinischen unternehmen genau
seit 1993 ist ein belgisches unternehmen
namens jan de nul für die meisten
wartungsarbeiten an bloß zuständig
du denkst jetzt wahrscheinlich wirklich
niemand hat einen protest organisiert um
die ausländischen unternehmen aus
argentinien zu vertreiben nun natürlich
gibt es da ein paar sektierer des
radikalen terrorismus die fordern dass
alle privaten unternehmen fluss verbannt
werden aber im moment sind auch sie in
der minderheit mit anderen worten
niemand bei sinnen will das
funktionierendes system ändern und dann
wirst du dich vielleicht noch fragen ob
diese wasserstraße wirklich so gut
funktioniert
nun ich nenne ich ein paar zahlen
derzeit laufen 80 prozent der ein- und
ausfuhren paraguays über diesen schuss
im falle argentiniens werden 70 prozent
des gesamten getreideexport über den
paraná abgewickelt und die eine
vorstellung zu geben 2009 10 hat der
hafen von rosario 79 millionen tonnen
getreide exportiert einigen berichten
zufolge ist der hafen von rosario damit
der größte agrarexport hafen der welt
aber wir reden hier nicht nur über
warenverkehr wir sprechen auch über
energie denn entlang des paraná gibt es
staudamm itaipú darunter jack erinnert
an zb erzeugen strom für paraguay
brasilien und argentinien
mit anderen worten der paranoia ist das
nervensystem dass diese drei länder
miteinander verbindet und du wirst dich
vielleicht würde ich fragen warum
sprechen wir über all das ist da ist was
schlimmes passiert nun das ist mal gut
auf
[Musik]
spiel mit dem feuer wenn es einen
dauerbrenner unter den planeten retten
engagierten promis dieser welt gibt dann
ist es der kampf gegen die abholzung des
amazonas vor allem dollar bis leonardo
dicaprio jede celebrity auf der welt hat
schon einmal gegen die abholzung des
amazonas protestiert und die frage die
sich viele von euch wahrscheinlich
stellen ist haben wir es wirklich mit
einem ernsten problem zu tun oder ist es
nur ein günstiger anlass um vor presse
und fans gut dazustehen nun die wahrheit
ist dass der amazonas eine noch
ernsteres problem ist als es scheint
[Musik]
laut einer studie die der beschreibung
verlinken werde gibt es einen klaren
zusammenhang zwischen abholzung und
niederschlag je mehr hektar wald
verloren gehen desto weniger regen fällt
natürlich enthalten diese komplexe
modelle viele unbekannte zum beispiel
erreichte die abholzung im amazonas
gebiet im jahr 2004 ihren höhepunkt
seitdem hat sich die abholzungsrate
verlangsamt das heißt aber nicht dass
das problem verschwunden sei jedes jahr
gehen tausende von hektar waldfläche
verloren nun viele menschen brennen
große flächen wald ab um nur pflanzen
anzubauen am ende des tages lag der ball
sehr wichtig für die umwelt und den
planeten sein aber seine wirtschaftliche
profitabilität vor ort ist gleich null
mit anderen worten es gibt einen sehr
hohen anreiz große waldflächen in
ackerland umzuwandeln und all das
erklärt warum die brasilianische
regierung maßnahmen wie diese er dreist
brasilien verlegt truppen in den
amazonas regenwald und verbietet
brandrodung doch egal wie viele soldaten
brasilien losschickt der schaden ist
bereits angerichtet die auswirkungen der
abholzung des amazonas inside 2014 zu
spüren seitdem leidet die stadt sao
paulo mit ihren mehr als zwölf millionen
einwohnern unter häufigen wasser
ausstellen doch was 2021 passiert ist
war einzigartig was kam waren die
apokalyptischen reiter der dürre die
whitewater der trockenheit schoss er an
brasilien steht vor der schlimmsten
dürre periode seit 91 jahren und warte
ein moment denn das ist noch nicht alles
das problem der wasserknappheit in
brasilien macht sich nicht nur bemerkbar
wenn du den wasserhahn aufdreht und es
betrifft bei weitem nicht nur die
landwirte eigentlich ist es ein problem
dass die gesamte wirtschaft betrifft
denn so wie andere länder ihren
energiemix aus atomkraft oder kohle
stützen ist brasilien auf
wasserkraftwerke angewiesen wasserkraft
ist der unter normalen bedingungen eine
stetige und verlässliche energiequelle
auch bei windstille und bewölktem himmel
heute kommen 65 prozent der energie
brasiliens aus staudämmen es stimmt zwar
dass das land in den letzten zwei
jahrzehnten alle anstrengungen
unternommen hat sondern energiequellen
zu diversifizieren
doch im jahr 2001 macht die wasserkraft
90 prozent der brasilianischen energie
aus trotzdem sind die brasilianer noch
immer sehr abhängig vom wasser und das
erklärt warum der strompreis in
brasilien in die höhe geschossen ist er
ist so stark gestiegen dass
entscheidungen wie diese getroffen
wurden
brasiliens ist angesichts der
wasserkrise vermehrt auf freiwillige
stromrationierung aber worum handelt es
sich bei dieser freiwilligen energie
rationierung ganz einfach die regierung
hat sich an die großen unternehmen in
brasilien gewandt und sie gebeten ihre
arbeitszeiten umzustellen wenn sie es
schaffen ihren verbrauch zwischen vier
und sieben stunden pro tag zu reduzieren
erhalten sich von der regierung einen
finanziellen bonus im moment vilmos
szabo keine strafmaßnahmen ergreifen die
frage ist aber wie lange sie diese
maßnahmen aufrecht erhalten können die
ihr wissen es nicht was wir aber wissen
ist dass brasilien nicht das einzige
land ist das von der dürre betroffen ist
es ist nicht einmal das größte opfer der
krise das eigentliche drama kommt erst
noch haltet euch jetzt mal besser fest
tragödie flussabwärts liebe zu beginn
dieses videos gesagt haben entspringt
der paraná floss in der brasilianischen
region minas gerais mit anderen worten
die dürre in brasilien wird sich auf
alle länder aus durch welche dieser
fluss fließt in rosario argentinien
liegt der flusspegel derzeit unter einem
meter während er früher etwa drei meter
betrug
[Musik]
das bedeutet dass die schiffe ihre
ladung reduzieren mussten um
weiterfahren zu können aber wir reden
nicht nur über argentinien ein weiteres
land das betroffen ist ist paraguay was
die hälfte exporte park usd nach
brasilien oder argentinien und die
exporte werden über die flussfahrt
abgewickelt das heißt entweder über den
paraná fluss oder über den paraguay
fluss aber es spielt keine rolle ob wir
über den einen oder den anderen zu
sprechen beide werden bald ausdrucken
und deshalb musste das land verzweifelte
maßnahmen ergreifen
notstandsgesetz der flussschifffahrt
verabschiedet und baggerarbeiten
genehmigt im grunde genommen musste
paraguay einen großen teil der mittel
welche für corona maßnahmen vorgesehen
waren zum ausbaggern der flüsse umleiten
wir sprechen hier von 21 millionen
dollar die für die flussbett reinigung
von paranoia und paraguay bestimmt sind
gut das klingt nicht nach gewaltigen tun
aber mehr hat das arme land einfach
nicht und dieses geld ist nur ein
absolute note behelfen denn das
hauptproblem bleibt mittelfristig
weiterhin bestehen
und wenn paraguay probleme hat ist
argentinien nicht viel besser dran die
dürre beeinträchtigt 70 millionen hektar
anbaufläche die berühmte argentinische
pampa ist am austrocknet und das wenige
soja das auch angebaut werden kann kann
quasi nicht mehr abtransportiert werden
und verrottet um die eine vorstellung
vom ernst der lage zu geben
argentinische exporte haben sich
schlagartig um 300 prozent verteuert und
sind somit auf dem weltmarkt nicht mehr
konkurrenzfähig zu vergleich das problem
ist so ernst dass argentinien paraguay
und brasilien sich darauf geeinigt haben
die schleusen des e-type buch staudamms
weit zu öffnen um etwas wasser in die
schiffbare flüsse zu leiten aber auch
dabei handelt es sich nur um eine
notlösung mit anderen worten die türe
des paranal macht die suezkanal krise
die damals die titelseiten vieler
zeitungen füllte so ein witz
denn dort reicht es ja aus ein schiff
abzuschleppen hier sprechen wir jedoch
über eines der besorgnis erregendsten
langfrist probleme der gegenwart es
könnte der endgültige schlacht für
argentinien seien von allen betroffenen
ländern hatte argentinien die
schlechteste erfolgsbilanz schon vor dem
corona virus in argentinien unter einer
verheerenden wirtschaftskrise das corona
virus und das miserable management der
regierung haben zu einer massiven
abwanderung von unternehmen geführt
jetzt fertigt er die dürre in paraná das
wenige was in diesem land noch übrig war
die frage ist nun was denkst du was in
argentinien passieren könnte gibt es
eine möglichkeit dieses problem zu lösen
reicht es einfach zu warten es ist
wieder mehr regnet oder er gibt es eine
möglichkeit zu verhindern dass sich eine
solche krise wiederholt der immer sind
wir auf eure meinungen zu diesem thema
hochgradig gespannt ich hoffe also dass
ich dieses video gefallen hat falls ja
geht uns bitte einen like teilt mit uns
freunden und vergesst nicht das abo mit
glöckchen und keines unserer videos zu
verpassen machs gut und bis bald
[Musik]